Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the chapter of patience authored by
the 52nd narration
goes along with the 51st narration
that we had briefly read yesterday
morning.
[Silence]
for.
He mentions here a narration on the
authority of Mas
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
Sam
said
indeed there will be after me
great
oppression overstepping
and things from your leadership that you
shall see that you will reject. act
that you that do not exist today in
our leadership. So the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam says
after me
and after me here after him. This is a
reference not only to his sunnah, not
only to his person sallall.aii wasallam,
but also to his sunnah and his legacy.
when the majority
of the leadership of Islam will be led
by his companions the
Abu Bakr and Omar and
Ali, this is considered to be the golden
age. They have a sunnah which is an
extension of his sunnah sall.ai Wasam.
In the narration of
the prophet Sam
said
and so he said hold to my sunnah and the
sunnah of my rightly guided successors
after me. So their sunnah or those
things which they instituted in the
expansion of the Muslim Islamic it is an
extension of the prophet's saiam
after that as the prophet mentioned it
will become a kingdom a kingship just
other kingdoms it will
be led by Muslims there will be good
aspects there will be bad aspects there
will be the oppressive leader and there
will be the just leader. And so the
prophet here
says
after my departure
there will be a
leadership
that will be oppressive
specifically
is when the leadership takes what is
belonging onging to the people and keeps
it for himself, keeps it for his
minions, keeps it for
keeps it for those who are close to
him. This is referred to as it doesn't
just have to be money doesn't just it
could be also position.
When we have positions of authority
amongst us, who is to occupy those
positions of authority? The best amongst
us, those who are most qualified are the
ones who are to who are to occupy
those positions of authority amongst us.
However, when there is oppressive
leadership or misguided leadership, what
happens? Nepotism,
minionism, right? And so when this
creeps in and it changes from being a
meritocracy where the qualified
occupy those positions and turns into a
eth meaning that which is the right of
the qualified
it now becomes something that is
specific to the leader. He distributes
it as he sees fit. Right?
and it could as well be things like
riches, things wealth, etc. All of
these things, things that are supposed
to be shared with the people, he keeps
it for himself.
That's one. The second thing that you
will see that our prophet warns us is
that
and things that you all will reject.
innovation,
changes in tone, political and
otherwise,
, etc.
Things that, , are are disobedience
from the people in power. Might even be
blatant public disobedience to an
extent.
Judges might start taking bribes, things
that. corruption when it starts to
creep in.
A man once was sent by the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam to collect these
zakah.
And as he's going to collect these zaka,
when he arrived at some of the ranches
that he was to collect zaka
from, the people giving zaka that year
started to
started to give the collector
gifts,
giving him gifts. They didn't bring
these gifts to his house. They didn't
look for him to give him these gifts.
Before he was the prophet's collector of
zaka. Now all of the sudden he has this
position where he's collecting zaka.
They're giving him all of the zaka. But
a little gift too. This is for you. We
know you work hard and you know you it's
really a a labor of love. You're so
selfless, you know, and and you're
you're this is for you. We want you to
have this. Okay. So, here's my zak for
the year and this is for you. And so he
came back and said, "This here is zaka,
but these over here, this is for me.
Somebody gave me these as a gift." And
so the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
immediately
rejected this. Immediately prohibited
this. Why? Because this is exactly how
this is exactly how
corruption begins. All right? The
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said if
that is truly a gift why didn't you sit
at your own home and wait for them to
bring you your gift. That gift is only
because you are in a position of
collecting zaka. This year they'll give
you zaka. Next year they'll give you
zaka. the year after. Well, you know,
I'm having a hard year this year. Things
are tough. Well, you know, don't worry
about it because no gift comes to a
position of power without strings
attached. That's how it works.
That is why
governments become so corrupt and so
entrenched in corruption.
And so
the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam mentioned
that these things were going to rear
their head after his departure and they
must they always will. Did he eradicate
corruption in his time? He eradicated it
from public view. Yes. But evil will
always exist. It's just an issue of
keeping it out of public. And so as
things become weakened, as the Muslim
empire expands at such a rapid and
exponential speed, it becomes nearly
impossible for this not to happen. And
so the companions asked, they said,
"What should we do in response to this
corruption? Should we fight against
them? What should we do?" He said to
You give the rights that are expected
of you and you ask Allah for the rights
that are for you. Why? Because as the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam mentioned,
just because
we have a bad leader doesn't mean that
we can be bad followers. And we don't
base our actions on other people. We
base our actions on the Quran and
[Arabic recitation]